you are by now probably used to the idea
of measuring angles in
degrees we use it in everyday language
we've done some examples on this
playlist where if you had an angle like
that you might call that a 30 degree
30 degree angle if you have an angle
an angle like this you could call that a
90 degree angle and we'd often use this
symbol just like that if you were to go
180 degrees
you'd essentially form
you'd essentially form
a straight line let me make these proper
angles if you go 360 degrees if you go
360 degrees you've essentially done one
full rotation and if you watch figure
skating on the olympics and someone does
rotation they'll say oh they did a 360
or especially in some type of some
skateboarding competitions and things
like that but the one thing to realize
and it might not be obvious right from
the get-go but this whole notion of
degrees this is a human-constructed
system this is not the only way that you
can measure angles and if you think
about it you say well why do we call a
full rotation 360 degrees and there are
some possible theories and i encourage
you to think about them why why does 360
degrees show up in our culture as a full
rotation
well there's a couple of theories there
one is uh ancient calendars and even our
calendar is close to this but ancient
calendars were based on 360 days in a
year some ancient astronomers observed
that things seemed to move 1 360th of
the sky or per day
another theory is the ancient
babylonians liked equilateral triangles
a lot and they had a base 60 number
system so they had 60 symbols we only
have 10 we have a base 10 they had 60.
so in our system we like to divide
things into 10 they probably like to
divide things into 60. so if you were to
if you had a circle and you divide it
into about six equilateral triangles six
equilateral triangles and each of those
equilateral triangles you divide it into
60 sections because you have a base 60
number system then you might end up with
360 degrees
what i want to think about in this video
is an alternate way of measuring angles
and that alternate way even though it
might not seem as intuitive to you from
the get-go in some ways is much more
mathematically pure than degrees it's
not based on these cultural artifacts of
base-60 number systems or astronomical
patterns to some degree
a an alien on another planet would not
use degrees especially if the degrees
are motivated by these astronomical
phenomena but they might use what we're
going to define as a radian there's a
certain a certain degree of purity here
radians
radians so let's just cut to the chase
and define what a radian is
so let me draw a circle here my best
attempt at drawing a circle
not bad
and let me draw
the center of the circle
and now let me draw
this radius
and let's say that this radius you might
already notice the word radius is very
close to the word radians and that's not
a coincidence so let's say that this
radius the circle has a radius of length
r
now let's construct an angle i'll call
that angle theta so let's construct an
angle theta
so let's call this angle right over here
theta
and
let's just say for the sake of argument
that this angle is just the exact right
right measure so that if you look at the
arc that subtends this angle that seems
like a very fancy word but let me draw
the angle
so if you were to draw the angle
so if you look at the arc that subtends
the angle that's a fancy word but that's
really just talking about the arc
the arc along the circle that intersects
the two sides of the angles so this arc
right over here subtends angle this the
angle theta so let me write that down
subtends
this arc
subtends
subtends angle theta let's say theta is
the exact right size so that this arc is
also the same length as the radius of
the circle so this arc is also of length
r
so given that if you were defining a new
a new type of angle measurement
and you wanted to call it a radian which
is very close to a radius how many
radians would you define this angle to
be
well the most obvious one if you kind of
view a radian as another way of saying
radius synthesis or i guess radii well
you say look this this is subtended by
an arc of one radius so why don't we
call this right over here 1 radian why
don't we call this 1
radian which is exactly how a radian is
defined when you have a circle and you
have an angle of 1 radian the arc that
subtends it is exactly one radius long
which you can imagine might be a little
bit useful as we start to interpret more
and more types of circles with with when
you give it degrees you really you have
to do a little bit of math and think
about the circumference and all of that
to think about how many radiuses are
subtending that angle here the angle and
radians tells you exactly how many how
the arc length that is subtending the
angle so let's do a couple of thought
experiments here
so given that
what would be
what would be
the angle in radians if we were to go so
let me draw
let me draw another circle here
so let me draw another circle here
so let me so that's the center and we'll
start right over there so what would
have happened if i had an angle what
angle if i wanted to measure in radians
what angle would this be in radians and
you could almost think of it as radius
systems so what would that angle be
going one full revolution and in degrees
that would be 360 degrees what would you
well based on this definition what would
this be in radians
well let's think about the arc that
subtends this angle the arc that
subtends this angle is the entire
circumference of this circle
it's the entire circumference
it's the entire circumference of
this circle
well what's the circumference of a
circle in terms of radiuses this is
so if this has length r
if the radius is length r what's the
circumference of the circle in terms of
r
well we know that that's going to be 2
pi r 2 pi r
so going back to this angle how many the
how what's the the the length of the arc
that subtends this angle is how many
radiuses this is
what's 2 pi radiuses this is it's 2 pi
times r
so this angle right over here
this angle
this i'll call this a different let's
call this angle x
x in this case is going to be 2
pi
radians
and it is subtended by an arc length of
two pi radius systems if the radius was
one unit then this would be two pi
times one two pi
radiuses so given that let's start to
think about how we can convert between
radians and degrees and vice versa
if i were to have and we can just follow
up over here if we do one full
revolution that is 2 pi radians
2
pi
radians
how many degrees is this going to be
equal to
well we already know this a full
revolution in degrees is 360 degrees
is
360. well i could either write out the
word degrees or i can use this little
degree notation there actually let me
write out the word degrees it might make
things a little bit clearer that we're
kind of using units in both cases
now if we wanted to simplify this a
little bit we could divide both sides by
2 in which case we would get on the left
hand side we would get pi radians
would be equal to how many degrees
would be equal to 180 degrees
180 degrees and i could write it that
way
or i could
i could
write it
that way and you see over here this is
180 degrees and you also see if you were
to draw a circle around here if you were
to draw a circle around here we've gone
halfway around halfway around the circle
so the arc length or the arc that
subtends the angle is half the
circumference half the circumference are
as pi radiuses so we call this pi
radians pi radians is 180 degrees and
from this we can come up with
conversions so one radian would be how
many degrees
well to do that we would just have to
divide both sides by pi and on the
left-hand side you'd be left with one
i'll just write it singular now one
radian is equal to i'm just dividing
both sides let me make it clear what i'm
doing here just to show you this isn't
some voodoo
so i'm just dividing both sides
by pi here on the left hand side you're
left with one and on the right hand side
you're left with 180 over pi degrees
so 1
radian
is equal to
180
over pi
degrees which is starting to make it an
interesting way to convert them
let's think about it the other way if i
were to have one degree how many radians
is that
well let's start off with let's let me
rewrite
let me rewrite this thing over here we
said pi
radians
pi radians is equal to
180
180 degrees
180 degrees so now we want to think
about one degree so let's solve for one
degree one degree we can divide both
sides by 180
we are left with
pi over 180 radians is equal to one
degree so pi
over 180
radians
radians is equal to one
degree this might seem confusing and
daunting and it was for me the first
time i was exposed to especially because
we're not exposed to this in our
everyday life but we're going to see
over the next few examples is that as
long as we keep in mind this whole idea
that 2 pi radians is equal to 360
degrees or that pi radians is equal to
180 degrees which is
the two things that i do keep in my mind
we can always rederive these two things
you might say hey how do i remember if
it's pi over 180 or 180 over pi to
convert the two things we'll just
remember which is hopefully intuitive
that 2 pi radians is equal to 360
degrees and we'll work through a bunch
of examples in the next video to just
make sure that we're used to converting
one way or the other